[Music]  welcome home good hunter what is it you  desire  [Music]  Jahna missed the home of blood  ministration you need only unravel its  mystery but where's an outsider like  yourself to begin easy with a bit of  yharnam blood of your own  whatever happens you may think it all a  mere battery  long ago old Liana was overrun by the  plague of beasts and left to rot and  decay and now the only voice is heard  there are the howls of beasts  [Music]  our first the blood see shape that  soothes our fears but beware the frailty  of men  Atlanta makes us human makes us more  than human makes us human nor more  [Music]  good hunter your presence somehow  soothes what is it you desire and so the  hunt begins again  you